to me the key to teaching algorithms  well is just to be excited about the  material I think if you if you are  personally think these algorithms are  really cool and like wow how did they  come up with this and Wow I mean look  how this thing interacts with this thing  and magically it all runs is super fast  I think communicating that excitement  students pick up on it really quickly  and themselves get engaged in material  and care care more about it so I just  try to have fun with the material and  encourage the students to similarly have  fun learning it so it all comes together  occasionally we'll do demonstration but  a lot of the material in this class is  pretty theoretical so it's mostly board  work and trying to draw representative  figures and things like that